Stephanie is on the line starting off
this hour in Minneapolis hi Stephanie
how are you hi there thanks for taking
our questions today sure so I have a
question about how to navigate family
relationships when you start making like
good money so my husband my business
went from 0 to about gross to 20 in
about a year and a half it's going
really well the trajectory is up and
it's awesome but I've already started
getting some weird comments from my
family so over that time when we started
when we started making some money I was
pregnant we upgraded to a captaining old
mattress and just like a little thing
like that or we joined a nice gym in the
area and we get these kind of like a
little moneybags over here like odd
money and I think when they joined the
gym it was you must win the lottery to
afford that kind of stuff and so it's
just been weird and with the trajectory
of our business going up and making more
money getting to live the life that we
want to vacation and and things
eventually I just don't know how to
navigate what we already have is a
really good relationship with my family
but it's starting to get a little weird
holidays and stuff when we when we tell
them what's going on
so yeah just don't know how to do that
well a good relationship number one if
you have a good relationship and someone
says something that is hurtful you ought
to be able to say that yeah say you know
um you know I know you probably mean
anything by that but when you said that
it was like you were questioning whether
we should be successful and kind of hurt
my feelings I just need to say that to
you yeah so if you have a good
relationship you can do that if they're
just jerks then you would just have to
treat them like jerks and the thing is
what happens is this money doesn't cause
things money magnifies things that are
already there good things and good
things and bad things the quality of you
if you have a high high quality
relationship highly functional it will
become even more so with large sums of
money around if you have weak and petty
relationships that everyone acts like is
okay but on the surface it's not then
that will be magnified as you have
wealth if your if your daddy is proud of
you when you get wealth he will be very
very proud of you
yeah but if your daddy is a drunk and
his dysfunctional and takes his and has
to be king of the hill or he can't be in
a conversation because he's screwed in
the head and all of a sudden he can't be
king of the hill because your net worth
eight times his then your daddy is gonna
get worse you know you see what I'm
saying so that's what you've watched for
and I'd pick up Henry clouds book
boundaries because that's what this is
it's a boundary issue and and read
through it you'll enjoy it and it can be
with functional things as simple as you
know one things we've been very very
careful to do with the extended family
is just not to we just don't talk about
a lot of stuff that Sharon and I'll talk
about it will say well I don't know if
so-and-so can really emotionally grasp
that so we're just probably not gonna
bring that up yeah you know yeah and I
know we've talked about that with it's
been the family or friends or things
like that and yeah friendships
friendships is the same way I've got
friends that can't emotionally grasp
some of the things that we're able to do
for charity for ministries you know that
you know I can remember the first time I
gave a thousand dollars to something and
I can also remember the first time you
have a hundred thousand dollars to
something but you know that I can you
and I can talk about that now in front
of everybody but it's sometimes very
awkward with a friend of 20 years ago
you know and so I just have to be pretty
calm and go you know that's talked about
them more and me less and most people
like that anyway that's just good
conversational manners and in other
words I might not if
you went on a super super nice cruise
you don't have to tell everybody you're
not going for them you're going for you
and if you are going for them you
shouldn't be going you know just and I
quit buying cars for other people I got
really nice cars you know why because I
like driving them I don't really care
whether you like it or not I'll like
drive it that's why I got it
and with you you know and so but you
know occasionally a comment about a car
and spiral it must be nice you know you
can remember the little people oh my god
cheese you know grow you a spine really
and I grew up little people I've been
little people my whole life I'm just a
little people that got big that's all it
is so just chill your butt you know but
you know that's what runs through your
head but you can't say that out loud so
I will tell you that there's a certain
amount of awkwardness and weirdness that
goes with the territory but the same
thing happens in any area of your life
that you grow let's say you came from a
home that was not that didn't have a
faith and you became a very strong
person of faith and you grow in that
area well you're gonna get eye rolls
over that too right you know how's it
going over there they handle snakes
you know it's you're gonna get people
how's the cult operating nowadays you
know you're gonna get these snide things
from old friends and family that were
not there when you were that different
person but you've changed a lot now you
know and there's it's just envy and
jealousy and they're two of the two the
devil's work tools and then they are
different and it's interesting to study
them it's a good it's a good discussion
so thank you for let me get up on a
soapbox but you know jealousy is I'd
like to have what you have and that's
saying something like must be nice and
you kind of mean it like I'd really like
to have that I'd like to have gone on
that trip or about that house or
whatever envy is I don't think I can
ever have that so I don't want you to
have it either it should be taken away
from you
and that's envy and you see both of
these things pop up in the political
landscape these days with the whole
wealth inequality argument and that kind
of thing you know the evil rich people
see that that's true straight-up
jealousy that's really envy because I
shouldn't have that because I don't
think I can ever have it and that's the
that's the same thing but you just watch
for that stuff and then you can address
it or you can choose to say I'm gonna
limit my conversations about those kinds
of things worst case is that the person
is toxic enough old friend or family
that they have to you have to distance
yourself from them because they're never
going to accept that you're winning and
you not winning to please them as an
absurd idea
you can't go oh I'm gonna fail at
business because Bobby is gonna be upset
if I win well screw Bobby no I mean
Bobby's just gonna have to take a ride
you know it's crazy I can't do that so
there's a Bobby in the booth and they're
all laughing at him in there no not you
Bobby different Bobby oh my gosh all
right
hey good discussion it's one of the
things that happens when you win at
anything but it definitely happens when
you win at money